welcome to coffeezilla guys we have
a great guest for you today with quite
the story
today we have nick hill atar i hope i
got that name right
you were diagnosed with a form of
leukemia that's very rare
for your age and you specifically want
to talk about
the predatory alternative health scams
that are
out there and how they target cancer
patients i'm going to kind of hand the
floor over to you
walk us through the basics who you are
how you were diagnosed and then just
walk us through your story
yeah no sure thanks for having me on and
allowing me to talk about this because i
think it's it's really really prevalent
and that's a scary scary thing about
this all so
yeah i mean i was a normal kid i you
know
loved basketball that kind of stuff
until
until 17 and that's when you know i
realized after a few months of just
being so
tired all the time getting nosebleeds
but
never really expecting to have what
ended up happening right and
yeah i got carted off into hospital one
day after a blood test
they took me straight into emergency and
my doctor told me
you kill the good news is you're 17 you
have leukemia but the bad news is
you're 17 and you have the king and i
was
as everyone is like shocked and
devastated at that point
and yeah i stayed that way
for a long while until i found you know
the thing that actually got me out of it
wasn't
the usual motivational stories right
they actually pulled me down if anything
what what really got me out though
was i decided one day let's take a step
back
look at what had happened to me as if it
had happened to someone else
right and yeah i mean for the first time
in days
weeks i was able to actually look at
what had happened to me objectively from
there
and yeah from there it only made sense
to focus on
the stuff i could control right and and
to focus on that wholeheartedly and
trying to do everything i could
to get me out of this so yeah i was
diagnosed
young and that sucked but like
wasn't getting cancer younger also a
blessing in a way in that i could get as
much treatment as possible i could
have a family behind me rather than one
to care for right so
yeah i guess like that that that allowed
me to see that there's always
two ways of looking at things and it
made me realize that
you know what let's take the path that
leaves me happiest and healthiest and
yeah i mean so maybe the bad news was i
was 17 i had leukemia but the good news
was
i was 17 i had leukemia so i sort of
flipped that around
i believed in my doctors wholeheartedly
and
it was all going well i got into med
school actually um
the year after diagnosis and yeah
congratulations
yeah no thank you that was a big dream
of mine from
like early on but managed to do that but
midway through first year
i started relapsing and at first we had
no idea what was going on my blood
counts were going down and
i sort of knew in my heart though like
what else could this be other than
cancer right coming back and
i had acute myeloid leukemia and my my
chances when i was diagnosed with 10 to
20
but i'd survived five years because i
was picked up quite late
i had a really rare type of
hla subset on my mom's side so that bone
marrow transplant was
going to be tough to find a match for me
but walk back walk back a little bit
yeah a little bit for those of us who
are not uh
as bright with the leukemia stuff
what what type of look make it uh
you know for my audience who doesn't
understand anything of course
uh make it yeah
it's a bad type of cancer leukemia um
and there's something with your the
blood type or
or something that you needed a match for
the bone marrow
to explain that a little bit more i'm
sorry sorry that's it that's it that's
exactly it so
basically i had acute myeloid leukemia
which is a form of
aggressive leukemia that usually occurs
in older people
and you know it's it's still blood
cancer
but i i caught it pretty late on and
the major treatment for me like they
knew from the beginning
was going to be a bone marrow transplant
so in that procedure
rather than just i mean they also hit
you with a lot of chemo and radiation
but what they want to do is they want to
actually get someone else's bone marrow
inside you
right to make their blood cells in you
so like right now i'm actually pumping
out someone else's blood cells even to
this day
and what that does is your blood cells
also include your immune system it's
kind of mind-blowing
isn't it yeah yeah like it's actually
the only way a mammal can change blood
types
is by doing this procedure and i've had
two so i've had three blood types in my
life
fascinating like i'm a cancer researcher
now as well
in immunotherapy so this is like one of
the first immunotherapies that's crazy
you can like you could like study your
own blood at this point
you know what was really crazy i um
i went into the lab one day first one of
my first days and it's like a doctor who
was treating me
is now my colleague and i was like holy
crap that's so awesome
that's really cool how old are you now
so you were 17 when you were diagnosed
yeah so i'm 26 now so yeah
still kicking so we're good ways on from
the from the
five years good good let's get that way
back in the good so that kind of brings
us into
what we're here to talk about which is
okay you've had this
devastating i mean thing that
honestly is hard for me to fathom but
then
there's a compounding problem that sort
of happened which is
you're in these dire straits and i
always say
that desperation is the antidote to
skepticism
because it just makes anyone vulnerable
when you're when you're desperate
you're vulnerable to scams and
you came to me and part of the reason
you reached out is because you said hey
there's this
giant problem that no one's talking
about yeah i mean that's
it's been a big thing like um me being
diagnosed young
and having some really low chances
obviously i think
like it's a sad thing but it's almost
certain that someone
in your friends list will start popping
in and
and for me it was actually started by
families like
a family friend um they they talked
about this
guy who's a doctor and they're like
hey we should we should go to him he
seems to have some amazing things that
you could try
and yeah i went in like i was like okay
he's a doctor he's a scientist i know
um so he's probably got some things and
as you say
you're 100 right like you're desperate
and
i mean i was studying medicine i am a
skeptic
just from like you know even high school
days but
and medicine is like it teaches you to
evaluate evidence right and use that
based on your on on that that's what you
provide treatments for
and all that kind of stuff but yeah when
i went in and saw him
like he he started talking about first
off sodium bicarbonate
treatments and how alkalinity can
really reduce your chance of cancer and
i was like okay okay
it seems all right the thing is he
actually pulled out a couple of case
studies and there are some case studies
of spontaneous remissions occurring
after that kind of stuff
i now look back at him and i know that
like you know spontaneous remission
does occur in a lot of the treatments
that he was
in a lot of the cancer sorry that he
that they made those studies on
but yeah like that's that's when i
started believing him
but then he started talking about
vitamins
and how i needed to be on the proper
ones and get a good diet in me
and that the only proper vitamins that
you could get that were
super and amazing because they were all
naturally sourced so that meant like
somehow the chemical compounds were more
superior
but that was what i needed to be on
and he signed us up at that point for
amway
and that's i i believe
yes my whole audience just
took a collective sigh like oh no
this is gonna spin off the rails real
quick yeah
go ahead but i was i was lucky
that i didn't just completely believe in
him um
because the next thing he said was you
need to also be on a low sugar diet
he also put me on this weird sort of
instrument i have no idea
and he was trying to sell us these water
filters and all this kind of stuff i had
no idea if they were mlm products or if
they were just
random sort of things that he was doing
as well but he had like a stash of
amway vitamins so i think he was
somewhere in the middle
of the chain i had no idea by the way
what mlms were at this time
i but yeah the reason why i knew he was
not really what he was thought out to be
was because i asked him
when he was talking about low sugar
diets like a basic
first-year medical question of on
glucose metabolism like
why if if sugars power cancer
right and and cancers just keep eating
that sugar your body
will always have a normal level of
glucose unless you
are starving to death's point
right why can't cancers just end up like
breaking down your muscles breaking down
uh fat stores and getting sugar that way
right
and he was like i don't know so
then i asked him again and i realized
that he wasn't actually an md he was a
phd
and i was like okay this is a bit sus
and so you find this out right and so
then you're like
well this guy may not be the help but at
this
your family members just trying to help
you and you know some of that stuff
some of the okay i don't want to throw
alter all alternative medicine
under the bus because it's good to have
a healthy diet yeah like it's like
that's good
100 and that's actually like like
that's the thing i always took in right
like i was as you say
right desperate so when i was relapsing
i was just like okay
bring in whatever you have like if it
doesn't hurt me
it it can't hurt and yeah i mean
financially like that's the thing like
in australia we have free health care
right
because in america things could have
been very different but
we ended up like ordering this what
uh water alkaline filtration system that
cost a thousand bucks or something
so it did it did sort of add up there so
there's there's that
but yeah as you say like it can't hurt
to try
things and it also is probably
beneficial a lot of alternative things
in
in mild conditions particularly but
yeah when they're marketed as cancer
cures that's when it becomes dodgy
and and like post cancer as well this
guy was really
trying to actually like recruit me i
guess and
he invited me to one of the seminars and
that's when i realized
like wait this is like pretty bad if a
lot of
because he was i'm a medical student and
i knew a lot of the stuff that he was
saying was
pretty damaging because like there's
people there like
these are the same that was damaging for
example for example yeah so like he was
telling people
like oh these vitamins he was using
pretty much testimonials
getting people up on stage that he'd
worked with and
telling them that you know what these
vitamins they helped me
fix my diabetes they helped me fix my
heart issues i'm no longer on diabetes
medicines
and things like that and look like
you know if it's in the case of diabetes
if you manage your diet and things like
that you can control your sugar levels
and that's good that's something you
should be doing so
i mean that if he helped them it was
likely through his dietary and
lifestyle modifications that he inspired
in them but the hard stuff in particular
i think like one person
was like i don't need to be on medicines
anymore and like i just got a stent in
in my heart last week right and for that
you need to be on anti-platelet
medicines for like a year
right and if the guy stops that that's a
heart attack risk
right there and same thing for diabetes
right if you
if you're not on medicines that help
control it you could have accelerated
disease processes occur
and then he was also like trying to
recruit me to be like the guy who speaks
about cancer
and i was oh you're like a testimonial
for him now you're like the guy
who who took his med his little vitamins
and cured
got cured but really you got cured from
bone marrow
treatment yeah yes exactly
like that's the kind of thing he was
trying to do i wasn't
all horrid though because like i looked
up amway i didn't know
i still didn't know that amway what an
mlm was i think i only learned like
after john oliver's sort of thing um
on mlms but sure i knew but i saw so
many things about it being a scam when i
googled the company and i was like
yeah i don't want to push this up there
and then i saw him
like telling people look your cardiac
issues are fixed
you don't need medicines now and i was
like nah man that's
that's i'm not gonna come up and talk
about that like that's
that's life-threatening and yeah that
was like my first experience
with mlms and and here's another thing
about this all like so my parents my
family
they uh like i might be because i'm
indian as well so like i think this guy
by the way he was like a word of mouth
sort of thing so a lot of the people
there as opposed to you see a lot of
people doing the digital marketing thing
for mlms nowadays
back in those times or maybe just
because he he targeted an older
crowd like everyone there was more
elderly and he was making all these
crazy medical claims about various
things including cancer
at that point so yeah that was them and
i think
being of indian background and with
parents as well
that you know believe in like you know
diabetic medicines and stuff like that
too
like a lot of alternative stuff is also
pushed down so i got a lot of pressure
from my family to be on
various things and they're like why
don't you try and other things outside
of medicine to fix you and i was like
okay but i'll try them but it's not
probably not gonna work like and
stop making this my fault as well that
i'm not
getting better when i've got a cancer
that's
kills most people who get it right and
[Music]
yeah that's that's like another pressure
point that a lot of cancer patients
and chronic illness patients because i'm
i'm one of them too and i'm still
getting a lot of pressure
basically it's your fault that you're
not doing more
when meanwhile you're doing you're going
through hell and back to try to solve
this thing but because you're not doing
their version of what's going to get you
well
then now it's now it's like you're not
doing enough
and it's mostly because these people
make such wild promises i mean
your doctor can't say that this is gonna
cure you a hundred percent
but an alternative medicine guy can be
like oh yeah this is a hundred percent
cures people yeah of course you'll never
be on medicine again
yeah yep that's the saddest thing about
it right like
i actually i have a startup now as well
in the med tech sort of space we're
creating some medical devices
i know all about medical regulations i
know these guys are literally making
medical claims that are illegal and i've
talked to like the tga
i have friends who've talked to the fda
about these things
and they still keep going on because
they have no way to actually
like enforce these laws on
people like yeah
and that's the saddest thing because i
was a skeptic
and i was still like let's give this guy
a chance he's a scientist he must know
something he showed me his study and i
was
i was like you know taking those things
and i was like look
it may help and i was also like look if
these things could help
why not try them right and that's me uh
there's
other people who we know avoid treatment
right
and i i mean i think that's really
important to talk about real quick i
want to show people
an example now i apologize in advance
it's probably going to be pretty
i don't know if this is triggering is
the right word but it's going to
probably
be upsetting because i'm going to show
you a sales letter
of an example of what i know is
advertised
here in america this was advertised by
one of the largest
alternative medicine newsletters in our
country
you ready can you really disease proof
your body
nobel prize winning chemist unlocks
universal vaccine for cancer diabetes
heart disease
and alzheimer's survival rates soar
two thousand percent as tumors vanish
blood sugars plunges
arteries clear and lost memories are
restored
uh what yup that's
that's uh that's what they're talking
about but
then they you go and you read down i'm
gonna give you the you know spark notes
version of this and it says okay
now you kind of find out if you read a
while you learn about how bad big pharma
is
that there's this miracle molecule that
is the secret to the universal vaccine
two oxo l three o hexano one for
lactone two three in a diol wow
now what could that thing be this
miracle molecule they say that's a
mouthful so we're just gonna call it the
universal vaccine
okay so you get to the bottom and now if
you're let's say you're a cancer patient
and you're hearing all these amazing
stories about how you know uh
martha's alzheimer's got reversed right
would you like to know what that is the
universal vaccine is i mean you're gonna
have to pay
79 a year or whatever for it
but uh the universal vaccine
is vitamin c
like yeah
listen to that claim
nobel prize women chemist unlocks
universal vaccine for cancer
diabetes heart disease and alzheimer's
the four big killers hey let's just
solve all of them let's just pretend to
solve
why not that's
really frustrating because vitamin c
we know doesn't work in cancers and
yeah like that's another thing i guess
we're going to talk about
in a bit right in that there's a lot of
alternative
medical centers including like
compounding pharmacies in australia and
things like that that sell this
kind of stuff but yeah i like get i
routinely get
because i do the whole blogging thing
right and i've written a lot
on this sort of space i always get
messages
and emails from people saying exactly
this kind of thing
and it's that sort of marketing ploy
like you know
as a scientist i'm like expert opinion
that's like level
four on the base the base bottom level
of the hierarchy of evidence that you
use right we actually look at studies
and then
try and use reviews to base our practice
but
most people see there's an amazing
doctor
right that's unlock this thing and
it's so it's so easy to buy into though
when you when you're desperate as well
like
that's the saddest thing about it
because a lot of these patients
right they're they're not dumb they're
just
not as medically trained and also
they're desperate and they're they're
chemo sucks
right and yeah treatment sucks and
that's
that's the saddest thing one thing i
want to get to
is that you sent me a series of text
messages from a friend of yours who is
trying to
well essentially i mean harassing you
while you're like losing your mind in
chemo
would you like to talk about that a
little bit because that was so
unbelievably predatory to me i was
disturbed reading these text messages
yeah so yeah feel free to post them up
or whatever
um really mind um but yeah this guy's a
friend from high school
i guess this is like a typical sort of
mlm thing
and the thing the thing about it though
like he's always been
he'd always been bullied at school and
he actually had a his dad passed away
from cancer
as well he was still getting bullied so
i was like always sympathetic to him and
like one of his only friends sort of
thing and
yeah then he starts sending me like
messages the first time he pinged me
i was in middle of chemo and
yeah like over the next like you know
two three weeks he was like i really
want to come and see you
i really want to come and see you and
tell you about this amazing
juice that i really think could really
help people and i'm like
okay i've heard a lot of this before and
i've also like i was also like look
you're talking about your dad but your
dad passed away as well right
and and and like he's still using that
a lot and yeah i think like one of the
most shocking things though was like
a few months late like a few months down
the track he's
he kept messaging me week after week and
then he was like oh wait you have
leukemia
oh this this drug this not this drug
this juice or whatever
shown like in 86 percent of cases to
kill cancer cells and i was like
dude you've been telling me the last few
months that this is a perfect juice for
your disease and you don't even know
what the disease
was right and
yeah he'd ping me like at 5am 3am
kept saying like basically oh this is
really going to help you this is going
to cure
he's basically telling you hey get out
of that keem award and come visit me
i'll get
hook you up with some and he wanted to
sell it yeah i mean it wasn't like hey
let me give this to you
at home and you know under no illusions
that this guy
was altruistically trying to give nick
hill
all this stuff he was trying to
literally sell it to you
my dad actually ended up buying it right
and
tasted it it was pretty horrible but
like i drank that stuff and just to get
him off my
back and that's like you know
eventually like that's a lot of the
sales sort of tactics that these guys
use
so yeah that was
a friend let's say that sure
yeah i mean i'm sure that person to some
extent
i think to some extent people who really
believe in alternative medicine
may actually mean what they say they may
think they're on like a mission of
goodwill
to sell this stuff yeah maybe
but maybe at some level some of these
people
like the doctors who are selling this
stuff the quote doctors
who you know they're actually
chiropractors who are selling this stuff
a lot of
naturopaths are chiropractors yeah
i've actually been like i mean i've done
one
sample of i can't remember the company
but i think like it just
screamed mlm and this is at a point
where i knew where lmr mlms were from a
podiatrist
that's like you know a foot specialist
but not doctor
but i've actually had doctors give me
usana
vitamins at one point as well so it's
not just
chiropractors there's some doctors
trying to cash in on this as well
i don't know how you can be roped into
that but i guess
they do so it's it's really really
really sad to see that because
doctors are trusted and and it's such a
loser
it's i mean i hate to i hate to put it
in terms of economics
but the chronic conditions
are the most lucrative and you're
talking about
cancer is one of those things that
people will be
needing your drugs for years
that's what's so horrible about it yeah
yeah
that friend like he's in my dms and
sending me these messages but
like every single cancer group in on
facebook
um there's a lot of alternative cancer
groups which are even worse
like if you go in them every single post
is
big farmer sucks don't use chemo
and it's it's really really bad but even
in the regular cancer groups which are
often well moderated
there's people just messaging you like
hey i'm dming you this check it out and
it's always
they won't tell you the company name
they won't do anything but i think it's
like not just facebook
facebook messenger where a lot of people
are just pressurized into into buying
stuff there's like one
image i sent you of a guy telling
someone with cystic fibrosis which is
like a genetic condition which
is incurable he's he's like insisting
hey did your doctors really tell you
it's incurable
these dudes have lived with this since
they're like a few years old
like the audacity and the sheer
like lack of ethics there to target
these dudes
it's really really sad and they're
telling them they can cure this
incurable disease
yeah yeah unbelievable that guy was a
juicer
i can't remember
so even in these facebook groups this is
super prevalent and maybe
it's worth talking about the fact that
this stuff can
actually have adverse effects not
necessarily
the the bottles of juice themselves
but the attitude they instill when we're
constantly pushing this narrative that
big pharma bad random facebook karen
good with her little juice bottle uh
you you've looked into this stuff
obviously you're researching medicine
what have you learned about the outcomes
of people who do this alternative care
stuff
so like there are numerous studies which
have like you know looked
retrospectively at
uh cancer patients and like one of the
larger ones in particular
it no and they all show a consistent
trend towards this
level of mortality rates increasing when
you have
alternative medicine and alternative
practitioners come into the mix and
treatment
translation mortality rate you
alternative care you die more likely
you're more likely to die
two to five point seven times more
likely and that's a scary scary number
behind it and the reason why we know
is because people are more likely to
refuse chemo
radiation and even surgery which is like
the main
curative thing right in so many solid
tumors
and it sucks to get surgery but most
people
recover and get on with lives right
and that's where it's really pretty sad
and we're talking like
50 plus higher rates of refusing chemo
and things like that in people who are
brainwashed
yeah because the people who do the
alternative care they
may think to themselves oh it's working
it's working because
i mean you'll have to tell me how true
this is but with cancer it's not like
you
always are feeling bad some days maybe
you feel a little bit better some does
so maybe you think to yourself
my cancer is doing better when in fact
it's not
but because you're refusing traditional
medicine
and you're going towards this
alternative thing you don't really know
yeah and that's that's a that's a thing
like as well as this like
uh the people who provide these
alternative treatments
they don't keep records they don't do
studies
so they won't tell you about the people
they've lost right and
there are a lot of them i've lost a few
friends personally myself
who had options otherwise and
to things like you know low sugar
high citric acid diets and all that kind
of stuff
and yeah there's a there's another
really big thing
that i guess we're going to talk about
at some point too that i'm really
concerned about
and that is that there's a lot of
alternative therapy clinics out there
in like you know mexico thailand and
international like sort of areas and
they are right now like i've gotten
these ads targeted to me
i guess because i'm a cancer patient
right but right now
they're advertising on facebook and
these treatments literally they charge
tens of thousands of dollars um
per week and they were at one point like
gofundme's biggest
like reason for for campaigns was
these things and like literally there's
a study i
showed you they only looked at 220 cases
but found like
1.4 million dollars was raised in those
220 cases which wasn't
all of them but like that was raised
to fund these kind of operations oh and
facebook where they advertise
facebook some dude facebook is such
trash
so let me get this straight i didn't
think
that cancer was an ad vertical but
now all of a sudden i'm realizing oh it
totally is
cancer patient is like something they
know about you
by i guess you typing in keywords or
being part of groups
so then zuckerberg gets in there puts
you in the ad vertical for
you know cancer uh and then these guys
these predators and that's really what i
call them because i do believe this is
predatory advertising because what are
people gonna say no
no i'm not gonna pay ten thousand
dollars to save my life
they convince you they're going to save
your life and then you basically find
the money
bad people beg family members and then
it's just
you go there and get what what do they
do
like i've i sent you a bill for one of
them that
a friend of mine sent me and it was like
thirty thousand
dollars thirty three thousand three
weeks every single item on that bill
is like there's vitamin b17 which is
literally like a substance that you can
which is not a vitamin by the way it's
like this thing that these
non-doctors invented like
a few decades ago and just sold
just to make money it turns into cyanide
in your body
and then there's one i think it's called
the coley's choli's toxins i looked as
it is
yeah yeah that's one of them coley's
toxins they're apparently like
uh so i'm a tumor vaccine immunologist
researcher right and i've like looked
into these kind of things
and these companies are marketing them
as like it's a tumor vaccine sort of
thing
what it really is though it it may have
a slight impact
in increasing your body's immune
responses and stuff like that
which they propose can kill cancer but
like my own field
we know that tumor vaccines have like a
10 or
20 maximum efficacy rate when
being used they're pretty cool in that
they have low side effect profiles
and they essentially are just activating
your body
against your own cancer cells and like
relearning retraining the immune system
to kill them
that's cool these therapies though
they're just saying oh we'll enhance
your immune system
and we'll we'll try and get it to kill
your cancer
well even when you combine tumor
vaccines with that
sort of effect you get like 30 max and
that's in
one one tumor vaccine that's approved on
the market
that's allowed to be out there and
that's like
lower than the efficacy rates of many
chemos and
surgical options in that sort of space
so these
alternative centers i mean they might
have some
people that they fix but
the vast majority will not get good
treatment
you will never hear about them as well
because they don't report
they they're based in mexico and i've
talked to the tga
which is our regulatory body and i've
had a friend talk to the fda as well
um which is america's obviously
regulatory body and the reason they
can't prosecute on this
is that it's based overseas they have no
jurisdiction there
and meanwhile like facebook is making
tens of thousands
from these ads alone facebook won't ban
these ads
i've reported them i've actually had a
friend
who knew like you know a marketing a
high up marketing guy at facebook
and when i told him about this one
company yeah
they stopped advertising those things
for a little bit but
now they're back like literally i saw
the ads again
and also facebook like you could there
was a feature where you could check
which ads the page was running
a couple a year ago not even a couple
years ago like a year ago
now you can't and like i was i'm just on
the tip of the iceberg is that one
company i saw and actually call them up
and was
trying to see like what kind of stuff
they were offering
not because i wanted to but because i
wanted to expose them right
um but yeah like there's another
company which is even bigger and that
has you know
it has at least 22 employees at the
hospital
130 000 ish facebook fans
and they run ads their videos have
millions of views
and like they're turning over millions
per year
per month even because yeah i mean that
is
unbelievable is that
fair to life that one
is another one it's called chipset
hospital but verita life is one
as well that's like mainly social media
digital marketing that they use
uh chipset is sort of starting to go
down that line and there's like
literally another like five that i could
dig up the names for
and i know there's dozens of these
and they're advertising on facebook it's
it's millions in revenue probably to
facebook
a per year yeah all of this
really exists because in part
people don't trust traditional medicine
and part of that yeah part of that well
i guess another part of it's probably
just the advertising's way crazier with
some of the stuff
but part of the distrust of traditional
medicine comes from
in part the advertising that these
people keep
perpetuating i mean like one big thing
that every single
alternative uh medicine person
reinforces
is the narrative of evil pharma evil
doctors
uh you know your doctor your your doctor
at home might not be bad but he's just
naive because he doesn't understand the
system
of big pharma and how they're only out
to get money
and the thing is look i don't think
there's an honest
person in the world who will tell you
that farm is perfect
but the idea no way that big
pharma is out to kill people
that's ridiculous it doesn't even make
sense big pharma wants more patience i
mean
like they want more money it's like of
course if they want to keep them alive
how
why wouldn't they create the best
possible things and then people say
oh well they just want them like chronic
patients forever and it's like oh wait
those are you're talking about the guys
who created vaccines
like aren't those the things that fix
people but then when vaccines come out
you don't want to take the vaccines
because that's bad too
so the vaccines are bad but then the
chronic condition medicines are bad
everything's bad big farm is terrible
but okay go take my oxygen therapy
it's insane it is so so bad because like
being in med tech right i know i'm a
startup
i know there's like a bunch of there's a
bunch of companies i know that are
currently developing
various molecules if there was like
cancer like i could show you like
one picture which shows various
signaling pathways it's
so complex the reason why there isn't a
single cure for this is because
everyone's cancer is different
um yet alone like you know the hundreds
of different pathways
we haven't even explored like half of
them or even like
probably not even a tenth of them and
there's no easy way to fix cancer
because
it's really hard to fix right and
yeah yeah people i guess come in they
they make
they want to be the thing is big pharma
it isn't actually
like there's a lot of things that are
unethical about it and
you know they invest only 16 of their
budget into r d but 50
plus into sales the way they sort of
corrupt doctors is also pretty
concerning
yeah i'm like one of the first people to
say big pharma is
pretty bad in many ways but alternative
medicines
the thing about them is big pharma to
even get your drug approved
you have to show that it's better it's
effective that it's safe than the most
current therapy out there
right that's the only way you can as a
pharmaceutical
get your product out there the
alternative medicine industry is worth
300 billion dollars
that's a very conservative estimate by
the way of market
market share research and all that
number again
300 billion globally and that's like
minimum really
well then i mean i mean that right there
debunks the whole idea
that like that alternative medicine is
some david
knocking on goliath's door right that's
what they always say
hey yeah get some rogue doctor is trying
to fight against big pharma but you got
to buy now before
big pharma shuts us down dude these guys
are a 300 300 billion dollar industry
they're not
david they're not some tiny guy fighting
the man
they're the they're the other man and
they're one that doesn't even work
it's so stupid yeah so that's my blood
boy
that's that's the thing about them yeah
unlike pharmaceuticals they don't have
to approve they don't have to spend
millions to billions in research there's
no barrier of entry
all you got to do is get your product
there get a bit of digital marketing
spam
and go for it like that's that's what it
is that's it's like that's why
a like business proposition it's
like so much less risk it's so much more
profitable to these guys and that's what
it is
to them and ultimately
the customer are sick
cancer patients in a lot of cases i mean
terminal cancer patients are some of the
best
best marketing material because you take
a guy who's going to get better
definitely from traditional medicine
not such a good candidate but you take a
guy who's terminal
now you got yourself a customer on the
hook because they're going to buy
whatever you're selling
as sick as that is to even consider as a
concept
like i had one of my friends like he was
a really good friend as well like i
walked him through his whole cancer
journey and stuff
towards the end he had like i think
that's the thing like even my family
they put a lot of pressure on me to do
all
these alternative therapies but they
mean well right
but it's the guys behind them behind all
these therapies
that that are the real scumbags
that's the thing they sometimes really
believe in this too right
but yeah during his last few months he
was
like he had various different options of
treatments he wanted to try
but he was convinced by this guy that
you know a low sugar diet was what he
needed in the middle of
a bone marrow transplant which is like
like during chemos i used to eat when i
could whatever i could to get my weight
up
and my friend he ended up passing away
like he was just so emancipated he had
no strength at all
um and he was being told you know all
this kind of stuff
and look like you know i've seen uh
so many people like benefit from various
things right
in the alternative space they see a
naturopath who helps them with their
diet
things like that and that's great but in
like really serious diseases like
there has to be a limit where we
like it's hot like we can't
i guess they no never will be regulated
in what they say
it's hard to really enforce those claims
but at least like have the decency
or if governments could have the power
to
actually prosecute people who advertise
to people
that have cancer that are dying often
like that would be amazing but it's it's
sad to see it
still just keeps going and it just
it seems like there's no end and that's
the saddest thing about it like i've
been raving about this for a while
and i lost friends to this
and still goes on that seems to be the
most concerning part about this
you know if these guys were just making
a little bit of money
i mean it's almo it's terrible
but it's not a crisis but the fact that
people are literally dying
because they will not take the treatment
options because they have been told
by some loser podiatrist who fancies
himself a cancer
doctor that some pill is going to save
some some little vitamins gonna save
them instead of going
under chemo that's unconscionable
and that's the part that is the most
frustrating about this
um you know i wish i could turn this a
lot of my shows are much more
entertaining
but i there's not much that's too fun
about
this topic and it makes it so hard to
cover because i i don't want to
bring down my like it's it's you don't
want to be a downer
but at the same time i feel like this
topic is so critical to cover
which is why i'm so happy to have you on
today is because you're
you're a living breathing case study for
why this matters
right if you had believed those people
and gone down that path and refused the
bone marrow transplant
it's a good chance i wouldn't be talking
to you today you know the only reason
i'm actually still here is a site called
clinicaltrials.gov
so you know with my medical school
training i actually
like when i relapsed i told myself you
know
it sucks but let's try everything i
could have under my belt and try
using every skill i had right at that
point to save me
so i went on clinicaltrials.gov i looked
up
because i figured like you know my
doctors knew the best treatments
possible for me they knew that bone
marrow transplant is probably the only
curative thing but
clinical trials are where like you know
the future is so i was like that's where
we'll probably find random different
options
and when i went there i i then did like
a pretty much mini literature review on
myself
and i found a drug that actually was
going through phase two studies which
are like the
like the second sort of stage and before
the large randomized control study sort
of phase of
of getting a drug approved um yeah i was
going through those studies
and it had been shown in leukemia
patients like me
who had failed bone marrow transplants
and had to get a second one because i
needed a second one at one point
um that it improves life outcomes so
yeah like when i pitched that to my
doctors and they were like
look this could probably work and we
have a way of getting it to you and
like at first it was like uh this might
cost you
like 10 15 000 a month but they managed
to get it to me
for free even though i wasn't like able
to be enrolled into a clinical trial and
that's what saved my life right
science and actual
medications right that's what really
really helps
and like a lot of people are being
denied this sort of opportunity a lot of
people don't know about
clinicaltrials.gov as well because
someone's forcing this down their
throats
at the end and when they're really
really desperate
well i'll tell you this you know a lot
of times when you see something a lot in
ads
you know they have a huge profit margin
because they can afford to spend all
that money on
on advertising fundamentally
clinicaltrials.gov probably doesn't have
much of an advertising budget
compared to a lot of these these
alternative medicine people
um you know i think your story
is so powerful and i think you're doing
a really good job of getting the
awareness out there
um so yeah i really wanted to thank you
so much for coming on
is there anything else we didn't touch
on that you felt like
you absolutely wanted to to hit on with
your story here
um yeah i think like these
these i think we've got a lot through a
lot of the things that you know
i really really wanted to get out there
because
yeah i think the fact that this is all
targeted towards cancer patients
and that a lot of these people exist
and that you know 53 percent of cancer
patients are on some form of
complementary alternative medicine
and it's a whole huge industry that's
really under appreciated in how much it
impacts people
and yeah there's you know with all the
conspiracy theories anti-vaxxers
becoming mainstream these days
this thing is only growing so yeah
i know that that's another whole like
i've had anti-vaxxers like
literally come in they've taken photos
of me and said
this is before before a vaccine and this
is after and they had like a photo of me
not even pre-cancer but in chemo bald
and then one of me now like with my skin
issues and stuff
and like that kind of stuff like i can
deal with that
but it's just so sad to see and and
to like like these kind of dudes though
they post this kind of crap
and it goes viral because it's also
engaging a lot of people and it's it's
literally just
people are just trying to become i don't
know there's like these mad influences
and stuff like that
and trying to sell products and
that's what it is like if there's a way
that people can do it people will do it
there will be some scumbags who will
and it just keeps happening so that's
yeah
just a frustrating just a frustrating
way to end on a light note there nikhil
yeah i know i really am funny guys like
outside of all this
but yeah this is a bit more serious i
guess
i mean truthfully you seem like you're
really uh yeah you know
you have a great mindset great attitude
lighthearted dude
you know it's like and your story i i
love that you're now
in immunotherapy that's like what a what
way to go full circle with it that's so
cool
that's really cool man yeah and
seriously
like what you're doing as well is
awesome
that dan bilzerian breakdown was
great too um because as a poker player
like i've watched that stream where he
went
and started playing and he didn't know
what he was doing he was
asking his friend how to play like
one of the most standard hands possible
and i was like
dude this guy has no clue what he's
talking about no clue and
yeah like all the stuff that you do
though is really really really cool
and it's really really really good and
yeah
and yeah i guess i should talk about so
i like i
write you know about this whole
experience and stuff uh
i'm really bad at selling myself but
just yeah i'm on facebook there's
nikhilotar.com
uh i'll probably put a comment down on
the video we'll put some links you can
put a comment yeah
um yeah nikhilaltar.com
is the yeah i'll put a link and uh go
check them out guys you write about your
experiences
and all sorts of things we'll put all
your social down there and
hopefully some people who found your
story inspired which i think is probably
like
everybody uh we'll go follow you yeah so
like that's honestly like the best thing
about it is like
when i get messages from visions and i'm
able to talk them through and help them
in some way
yeah that's that's what got me starting
to do this and
yeah i'm always here to talk if i can
yeah appreciate it man thanks for coming
on the show
yeah thank you for having me
[Music]
comes along